merci madame la présidente madame la
première ministre l'inflation rogne le
pouvoir d'achat des français lorsque
nous vous proposons des mesures pour
vraiment baisser les taxes sur les
carburants vous nous brandissent et la
dette abyssale de notre pays pourtant
bien caché pendant les campagnes
électorales que nous venons de traverser
or pour le financement les républicains
ne cesse de vous inviter à faire enfin
des réformes structurelles par exemple
lutter contre les fraudes la fraude
sociale coûterait entre 14 et 45
milliards d'euros par an une des mesures
que nous vous avons déjà proposé et
l'instauration de carte vitale
biométrique
ce sont des cartes dont la puce contient
paramètres relatifs à des
caractéristiques physiques de l'assuré
comme ses empreintes digitales par
exemple c'est un système qui assure une
très grande fiabilité contre les risques
de fraude il n'y aurait plus de près de
cartes possibles et les cartes volées ne
pourrait plus être utilisé en effet
comment expliquer à nos concitoyens
15,8 à 2 millions de cartes vitale
circulent en trop dans l'hexagone
comment admettre qu'une tierce personne
utilise à l'hôpital ou chez un
professionnel de santé une carte qui
n'est pas la sienne comment admettre
qu'en cas de vol ou de perte la puce met
tant de temps à être désactivée quand
les le sénat l'a voté en 2019 mais vous
l'avez ensuite rejetée à l'assemblée
nationale au prétexte qu'une
expérimentation était déjà menée dans
quelques départements avec une carte
vitale dématérialisée et non biométrique
quel mauvais prétextes votre carte
vitale dématérialisée n'empêchera pas la
fraude madame la première ministre
qu'attendez vous pour généraliser
désormais la carte vitale biométrique
que nous vous proposons
[Applaudissements]